جازر متواصله ما تزال ترتكبها الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه عبر غاراتها وقنابل
العنيفه التي تودي بحياه عشرات من
الفلسطينيين بفعل شده هذه الغارات هنا في
مدينه رفح وفي هذه الليله تحديدا سلسله من
الغارات الجويه التي طالت عده منازل سكنيه
ادت الى ارتقاء عشرات من الفلسطينيين
واصابه اخرين هذا واحد من المنازل التي
قصفت يعود لعائله زعرب غربيه مدينه رفح
جنوبي قطاع غزه هذا المنزل الذي قصف من بل
الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي فجر هذا اليوم
وادى ذلك الى ارتقاء على الاقل 15 شهيدا
ما بين يعني هؤلاء الاطفال وكذلك النساء
وايضا من جيران هذا المنزل كما نشاهد في
هذا المشهد الدمار كبير جدا هنا في هذا
المكان وكذلك الخراب بفعل هذه الغاره تم
انتشال عدد من الشهداء من اسفل هذا المنزل
ومنازل مجاوره هنا ايضا وما زال هناك عدد
اخر اخر من المفقودين اسفل ركام هذا
المنزل هذه حفره كبيره احدثها القصف
الاسرائيلي بطبيعه الحال هذا يدلل على شده
القنابل الاسرائيليه التي تلقى على منازل
الفلسطينين وتؤدي الى هذا الكم الكبير من
الضمار والخراب في المنزل ومنازله مجاوره
التسعه المفقودين ما زالوا تحت انقاذ هذا
المنزل يصعب البحث عنهم في هذه المرحله
وبكل تاكيد هم يحتاجون الى معدات من اجل
يعني اخراج هؤلاء والبحث حتى عن احد منهم
وتضاء الفرص ان يكونوا ناجين من المستحيل
ان يجدوا اي احد الناجي تحت يعني الركام
بفعل هذه الغاره وهذا الدمار الكبير الذي
طال هذه البنايه ومنات مجاوره في المنطقه
الغربيه من مدينه رفح جنوبي قطاع غزه يعني
مضت ساعات على هذه الغاره ولم تصل حتى
معدات ثقيله وهذا يدلل على الواقع الصعب
لطواقم الدفاع المدني وانعدام حتى
سبل
امكانيه وصول هؤلاء وانعدام سبل تحرك هذه
الاليات التي تحتاج الى الوقود في ظل
انقطاعه وهذا يؤدي الى فقدان الكثير من
الفلسطينين حياتهم هذه منازل
مجاوره دمرت بفعل شده هذه الغاره على هذا
المنزل دمار كبير بطبيعه الحال حتى هنا
يعني جيران هذا الم
يحاولون جمع ولملم ما
يمكن جمعه من اسفل الركام هنا في هذا
المنزل المجاور هذه يبدو انها غرفه نوم
لعائله
فلسطينيه كانت في هذا المكان بطبيعه الحال
والركام ادى الى تدمير هذا المنزل ومنازل
عده هنا تقع في هذا
الحي اول شيء احنا احنا نازحين من فل
الهواء جينا هان عند اخونا عادل زعرب
الصحفي لما احنا جينا هنا قعدنا فتره
طويله ويعني كنا الحمد لله مبسوطين
ومرتاحين وجينا على الجنوب فلما جينا على
الجنوب اي اننا تقريبا علىق 72 73 يوم
موجودين ه ولكن اليوم على الساعه تقريبا
حده ده ونص صحينا لقينا الركام علينا عم
استشهدت عم استشهدت جوز عم تستشهد
ف فال يعني تقريبا من تسعه ل 10 ودعنا
استشهدت غير الاصابات واللي رجليهم ك
مكسوره وبلاتين فاحنا
مدنيين مالناش في حاجه احنا في الدور زي
زي ما انت شايف زي شا تبعونا وانا ه كنتين
نايم محمد ويحيى تعال في غاد ابن عمتي
وجوز عمتي كانوا هان ما قدرناش نطول لهم
هي احنا حالنا الصحفي عادل كان متابع
الاخبار لاخر لحظه كان يبعث وينزل على
النت صار قصف زنانه قلنا بعيد يعني مش
هالصوت كان وما فيش كان صوت شبابيك ولكن
صارت الضربه وكنا احنا صحينا وقنا اللي
كان مستشهد اللي كان تدور عليه
يعني يعني هي صحفي هو اللي هو اللي بينقل
الاخبار هلقيت هو صار الخبر يعني احنا
احنا ل وقتش بدنا نضل هيك وصلت الان معدات
الدفاع المدني وهذه الاليه الثقيله التي
ربما تم جلبها من خارج مدينه رفح لتبدا
البحث هنا عن دمين الشهداء المفقوده اسفل
عكام هذا المنزل وبطبيعه الحال يعني هذه
الاليات تسرع ربما وهناك فارق كبير بين
البحث بهذه الاليات الثقيله والبحث
يدويا هذه اليات الان تقوم بعمليات الحفر
بحثا عن هؤلاء المفقودين اسفل ركاب هذا
المنزل كما تشاهد حجم
الدمار الماهول الذي اصاب هذه
المنطقه يعني تشاهدون حجم الضمار في
المكان ضمار كبير جدا بفعل هذه الغاره
التي طالت هذا المنزل ودمرت منازل مجاوره
في حي زعرب غربي مدينه رفح وادت الى
استشهاد 15 على الاقل بينهم الصحفي عادل
زعرب الذي كان ينام في غرفته الملاصقه
تماما
للمنزل يهربون من الموت الى الموت هذا هو
حال النازحين من شمال غزه الى جنوبه هان
الشاعر لقناه الجزيره مدينه
رفح مجازر متواصله ما تزال ترتكبها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه عبر غاراتها
وقنابل العنيفه